[Musique]
ne nous voulons plus la face la
troisième guerre mondiale est
inéluctable il ne nous reste plus
beaucoup de temps pour rigoler alors
dépêchons nous nous avons joué à un jeu
très amusant
nous allons jouer au rébus vivant
regardez bien
cette somme doit irrésistiblement vous
évoquez le titre d'une vieille chanson
française non bien alors regardez voilà
qui va vous aider je suis le petit
patapon
je suis un empereur romain très méchant
je garde les moutons eh bien oui vous
avez compris le titre de la chanson
était il était une bergère
il était une bergère iran iru petit
patapon
il était une bergère néron héron petit
il était une bergère qui gardait ses
moutons d'antan qui garder ses moutons
etonnant non
[Musique]
ap